i'm kind of wanting another baby right
now you know what i'm saying about it
for number nine yo my little girl five
my baby girl so
is there anything in particular you're
looking for in a baby mama or
i think i'm going to china and get a
chinese uh
a and she gonna sign it over to me i'm
gonna be the mother and the father
so you're gonna go to china yeah i wanna
i want a chinese little boy
he's not gonna be miyagi hatch
sick ass bushy fake comb go straight
through that [__]
me wait wait hold on yagi hatch what
give me
you've been thinking about this yeah man
my law you're going over there and get
the egg
miyagi hatch yeah so you're gonna go
over there and you're gonna
i'm gonna pay for the head so he's gonna
sign it over to me
so you're gonna artificially inseminate
a woman
or are you gonna i'm trying to figure
out how this how this works man
i'm gonna put my sperm in the cup also
okay so you're not even gonna [__] this
girl you're just gonna like yo give it
to the scientists and let them handle
what they got to handle yeah they're
gonna put our stuff together
and then you got miyagi hatch what's
that name bro what is that
um it come from mr miyagi you know what
i'm saying okay okay
i was a karate kid fan you [__] with uh
cobra kai
who that is the new the new karate kid
show on netflix oh no i ain't on that
[__]
oh you gotta get on that i ain't gonna
know that it's like it's it's the
original characters
but like 30 years later so
the one dude who the karate kid beats
reopens cobra kai the dojo
and then they have a rivalry with their
kids it's wild bro
i gotta check it out if you're a karate
kid fan you gotta watch cobra kai bro
i gotta check it out so miyagi hatch
will be child number nine
you're just gonna cash out the egg and
have a a lovely
blasian baby right with the boozy fade
right you've put a lot of thought into
this man
right yeah i'm not going to be the first
one not to have a baby mother
are you just a life hack yeah i'm not
going i'm not going to have a baby
mother
celebrate me on mother's and father's
day here's the contract i need your egg
i need your egg you signed everything
over to me here's the funds
you're out it's like you're out the life
you'll never meet this kid you'll never
see this kid in your life
you're gonna be in china i'm gonna be
over here in the usa yeah
yeah damn you might you might uh
for anybody who who's you know cause
baby mama drama serious yeah man
i could do this by myself